- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
I am so bummed that I'm
not there in person.
You did such a great job in the film.
I really, next time you come,
I'm gonna give you such
a big hug. - Thank you.
You're so talented.
And you just turned 21 right?
- I did. It was my 21st on the 20th.
(audience applauding)
- Oh, that's a, that's a big thing.
How did you celebrate?
- I know. Okay.
Everybody keeps asking me,
what are you gonna do for your 21st?
What are you gonna do?
And I'm gonna be honest, it
was such an afterthought to me
because it was the week of like
the premiere of Disenchanted
and it was genuinely like
the last thing on my mind.
So, which always makes me laugh,
but when I was younger
I always used to celebrate
by going to Disney.
Ever since I was little,
I was fortunate enough
to have family out in California.
And we'd go celebrate.
And this year my Disneyland
was the premiere of Disenchanted. So...
- [Kelly] I mean, that's a pretty rad
that's a pretty rad 21st birthday present.
(laughing)
So you play Morgan in the movie.
You're all grown up, right?
- I do.
- Or you're a teenager?
- She's a teenager.
She thinks she's all grown up,
but she has a lot to learn.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Well, most teenagers
think they're grown up.
- Been there.
- So, yeah, so we've all been there.
But I thought you did such
a great job in the film.
It's such a, it's such a,
I always find it incredibly
an incredibly talented thing
to be able to act as well
as you do as sing and dance.
Like the whole thing is.
And also, for people that
aren't into musical theater
I think they're going to love it
because it's like a
different kind of escapism.
It's not like,
it's like you're, you're in on the joke
of almost breaking out into song.
That's what I loved about Enchanted.
And that's what I loved
about Disenchanted.
The storyline was brilliant
how it was played off.
And you almost got to play
two different Morgans.
Like that's kind of cool.
Like you got to play
two different versions
of your character.
Was that kind of more
exciting as an actor?
- Yeah, I mean, it's
definitely a challenge
especially when Morgan becomes this
like fairytale character.
She's obviously like such the opposite
of what we see her as this
jaded, sarcastic, bitter
in a sweet way kind of teenager.
- Yeah.
- So we see her totally
taken out of her element
and plopped into this fairytale universe.
And it's kind of funny because
there's this stark contrast
between her real personality
and we almost see it sort of kind of
trickling into this
fairytale version of her,
especially when we get to
hear her sing her song Perfect
about how that real bit
of Morgan comes through
about that pressure
that she feels to kind of be perfect and
and deliver and be this,
this epitomized version of
of what the people around
her believes she should be.
And I think everyone can kind of relate
to that pressure to know
exactly who you should be
and what you wanna do.
- Absolutely. I think
people can relate to that
whether you're in the spotlight or not.
That's just something that comes with life
I feel like.
You did, it was such a great job.
I mean, killer job.
So you, you shot in London.
I love London.
I hear that the weather didn't
cooperate though, right?
- No. It's so funny.
We saw this song called Perfect
about this perfect Monrolasia morning.
And what was it doing?
It was hailing all day.
It was snowing all day.
Sleet, freezing rain. Um.
So, uh, what you see is
the little bit of the magic of Disney
giving you bright blue sparkling skies
on a cloudy,
windy, stormy day.
And yeah. - Drab
- Yeah, drab definitely.
We were like rushed
under tents every time it started hailing.
And the second it would stop
they'd be like, oh, it's clear.
It's clear.
Everyone, everyone all right,
pictures up and action.
And we'd be like, it's
another perfect Monroe.
Like just thrown right into it.
- Wait I thought it was just like raining.
It was hailing?
- Hailing. I had like a golf ball sized
like hailstone in my hand at one point.
We tried to keep going
through it sometimes.
My director just didn't wanna call cut
cause it was like, we
got this, it's going.
And all of a sudden he had
to because there were just
hailstones bouncing off
my head in the shot.
And then a gust of wind
- You can like get a concussion from that.
(laughing)
- Anything for the magic.
- Oh my gosh.
I, I just wanted to say you,
I'm so bummed I'm not there
cause literally, you, the whole cast
y'all all did such a great job.
It's sometimes hard, I feel like,
to do a sequel of something
so many people loved
and were captivated by
and loved in the first place.
And I literally said this to
my executive producer, Alex.
I watched it and I was like,
I loved it more than the first one,
which I didn't think was possible.
It was so well done.
And the storytelling was so cool
how they flipped it.
We're such a fan of you.
Please come back whenever
I can like hug you.
- Thank you Kelly.
It was such an honor.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- Seriously.
- Oh man, I'm such a fan.
Everybody. You can see
Gabriela in Disenchanted.
You're gonna wanna see it.
It's on Disney Plus.